we had a female trucker
uh that canceled couldn't make it in
here
and you know that's just the way it is
sometimes out there on the road
you know that's why the road comes in
different patterns you know you can get
a
interstate it keeps going you get an
intersection meets up with something you
get
cul-de-sac you get dead in
you get um other roads
so trucker canceled
so you know the podcast is going well
when a
female trucker cancels on it
gasoline females you know just ladies
out there burning gasoline
18 wheeler [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying legitimate women
um what else happened i got rejected by
a woman i don't know if
well not even the trucker i didn't think
about that but um
a i hit on a woman and
got rejected uh i'll tell you what
happened so
you know i went to this place out here
and we're coming out to you live right
now from the central east out here
and and i went to a locale here
local shop and they sold crepes
crepery and
i don't know what a crepe is but i
didn't care once i saw this lady working
there i said all right
you know i'll eat them until you know
she and i are married if i have to
um they had a girl in there and i saw
her and
you know i made some small talk and it
was
it was awkward because we both had masks
on you know uh
having a mask on
it's kind of like the beginning of like
um shrek or whatever
you know because you don't know how
anybody really
you're not getting the full package
you're just kind of getting that
japanese package of somebody
you know kind of snout up or mid snout
upwards
you know you're kind of getting that um
you know like everybody's kind of a
desert nine
you know when they got that middle
eastern
you know a lot of middle eastern women
they wear the
kind of that word yarmulke whatever it
is that
that muffler you know they wear that
front muffler you can't see them
i was in uh saudi arabia one time at the
airport
and they had a man there and
fat fella i'll be honest with you really
was and i had
if i could think of another word to
describe him i would use it
but i cannot and this one this man was
what you would call a fat
fella and he uh had about five women
with him all of his wives and they all
had on that um
you know just that little kind of
they're all wearing like a what's behind
door number one kind of curtain right on
their face you know you can't see them
all
so that's called that desert nine you
know where that desert eight everybody's
kind of a desert nine when you can only
see the eyes
so i went in there and i'd seen her and
i like you know was nervous
and anyway you know i went in there and
i went in there a follow-up time because
i'm the kind of guy that'll show up
somewhere
fall in love with a woman that works
behind a counter i don't know if you've
ever done this but i'll
i'll go somewhere fall in love with
somebody who works at the place
and then try and and then go back to the
place
to try and profess my love or make a
connection so
anyway so i go back and i was nervous
and we talked about mma fighting we
talked about adult male
you know uh you know fighting and so i
figured i would try and talk about that
again when i saw her
i couldn't remember her name
and so i was like hey remember me
you know what's your name and she's like
oh my name is
you know clara i believe it was her name
and
so then i was like oh
uh have you been watching any of the
fights
and she said no i haven't and then
i was like so you ever like are so
nervous like you can't even hear what
the other person is saying
you're just like oh have you ever
watched any of the fights
and you just you ca even no matter what
their answer is your next question
is gonna be something like do you have a
boyfriend
you know uh so she said i don't know
what she said
she might have who knows she could have
been calling the police
but i was like go do you you know have
um maybe we should watch the fight
sometime
and and that was kind of weird because i
didn't
i don't even know kind of how she
responded if she was like yeah or maybe
or um and then i was like oh do you have
a boyfriend
and that's how i said it too like do you
have a boyfriend
like i just got so
just i was just strung up you know just
like when you see a rabbit and he's got
one of his legs caught in the uh
in that wire you know do you have a
boyfriend
and that's how i was verbally you know i
was that verbal
kind of hung rabbit and
she said i do and i didn't have a plan
for her having a boyfriend
i did not have my plan was
i i ask her out and she maybe says
yes or no i guess was also
i mean that's probably that's always
that's the biggest option but
i didn't have a plan for when i was
going to think she says
dude i'm making this story so long so
i was thinking okay i asked her and then
she said she
says no i don't and then i follow up
with oh well maybe i could take you out
sometime or i could buy you something
that's not a crepe you know or something
just a chill line
well i said you have a boyfriend
and she said yes and so when she said
yes i couldn't
it was it would have been weird for me
to follow up with oh well maybe we
should go out sometime
so i didn't know what to ask her so i
just
asked her name again
and i was like oh what was your name so
it just wasn't
didn't make it didn't make any sense man
uh
it just didn't make any sense man um
so anyway oh and this was the worst part
then then i had to
i'd already ordered the food so i had to
sit there she said yes i was like oh
what was your name what is your name i
said what is your name
what is your name and she told me her
name again
and then the conversation was just
and then she's like giving me like my
plate and fork and knife that comes with
your food that you order and you just go
sit down at your table and then it comes
out
and i was the only person in there so
now i have to sit and i
this is where i really messed up i sat
facing the counter
i sat facing her at the counter and then
i had to sit there and just eat a crepe
which is the loneliest saddest thing you
can eat as a rejected man
it almost feels like one of those
japanese game shows like oh you lost you
eat the crips you know
and so i'm sitting there just eating
this sad
every bite tasted like this girl did not
like me um
but i did it i did it i went in there
i asked her out i didn't get
she didn't i there was no option
and i asked her her name again and then
i said
and point blank ate a crepe in front of
this woman
very very sad um
very very sad so so anyway if you've
ever been rejected
if you ever tried and failed with a
woman um
[Music]
which i'm sure you have or you wouldn't
be listening to this podcast
uh then i'd love to know about it
and i'd love to hear the sharing of it
and if you can hit the hotline and keep
it concise you know
um and hit the hotline nine eight five
985-664-9503
and let me know about that moment let me
know how you handled it or how you
didn't handle it
the succeeding is in the trying that's
where it is
that's where it is so
if you've ever been rejected bro
rejected nation son you feel me gang man
we out here man we out here
let's get into the episode
this is paul coffin holy ghost fire
i got the holy ghost fire and it's
burning in me
[Music]
i got the holy ghost fire burning in me
got the holy ghost fire and i'm burning
down the streets
i got a sweet little battery at your own
in a caddy with me
[Music]
i got a sweet little patio
i got a whole lot of product for my holy
ghost mama she making sweet eyes with me
don't let me down i'll swing home
oh a sweet mama don't let me down
[Music]
if you knew the truth about me ain't no
way in hell girl
you'd stay
have you disappointed a woman in your
life riley mal
oh have i i definitely have
and how do you feel about it now and now
that some time has passed
i would say pretty great because she
wasn't the one
and in hindsight how do you know that
she wasn't
i think it was just the feeling i just
had a strong feeling she wasn't the one
but at the time he had a feeling she was
huh oh of course
and what was it you think leading you
down that down that path to thinking she
was do you think it was naivety do you
think it was
um sensualness you know do you think it
was uh
the devil what do you think it was
really no
i think she just um i don't know she
just
she was acting really different and odd
and
um like what was she doing like what do
you mean like walking like sleepwalking
or something
well apparently what i was told is that
um she's pregnant i was like haha
what um so then i
fell in love for a pregnant woman pretty
much and i had no idea because she
wasn't showing yet so it was it was very
early in the stage
and i i literally had no idea that
pregnancy the first three months they
can trick you
that's the thing about leeway that's
called leeway riley
and that's where you know a woman will
have a certain amount of time they can
still trick another man
they get pregnant over here they get
pregnant with jerry
and then they telling lance oh i love
you you know i love you come
you know spray in me and then they trick
you and say oh yeah you you know
you must have a strong seed i got that
six month baby
you know i got that little hatchling
right here six months
you know that that little premature bad
boy and he comes out weighing
a pound pound and a half some of these
children now
you know half the wombs out there they
you know you see a womb
up close on camera and the windows are
busted out in it
half these women out here they got you
know they got cardi b blaring out of the
damn
second floor of their womb you can't
even know you don't even know what's
going on anymore
you know it's all people's thought and
people you know somebody's
you know you hear somebody stealing a
person jumping off a rooftop
of the damn womb and you're like what is
going on here
but that's where we are right now a lot
of these pre-packaged wombs a lot of
you know these uh prefab
you it used to be back in the old days
riley a woman had a decent womb in her
you know about it you heard about it
yeah definitely
and then now you get these lady they got
the dams you know you don't know if it's
a womb or a damn ziploc bag in there
you don't know it's not as reliable as
it once was you back in the day they had
a woman at a damn concrete womb it was
something
you know that a bird's nest in the
corner they had it was there was more
there was something there there was
something
had a doorbell on it you know it was a
damn real place
and now you got these you know they got
somebody smoking on the porch you don't
even know i got the guy
so it's just it's a different time man
it is a different time what's going on
um what's going on
i was thinking the other day about
about racism because obviously i think
about it a lot
and we've discussed it before on here
riley
would you agree with that
well i think here's what i'm thinking is
nowadays you see a lot of children a lot
of mixed children
you know you see somebody and we talked
about it last a couple weeks ago there's
somebody's japanese and uh
and filipino you know
or you see somebody that's um you know
from delaware
and also somebody that's uh malaysian
you know malware they'll call them or
whatever
but when i was young they called a mix
oh look at that little mix fella
you know you'd see a kid he'd have a
white body one black leg
you know you'd see a kid who had a
little you know maybe he was ten percent
uh you know maybe he was ten percent
um pinoy
and he'd have one kind of lean eye you
know
it was just different man you'd see you
know but they call a mix so that little
fella's mix look at him
you know you'd see a little uh you see a
black kid but he'd have long blonde hair
you know and he'd perm his own hair at
night
he's like oh damn he's something you
know
so it was just a different time people
were more mixed but i'm thinking that
because there's still some racism out
there
you know and i'll name a couple of
groups that do not get along really well
or they get along well but there's still
some tension that's a better way to say
it
black and white
chinese and black
also mexican and black in prison
okay and this is all stuff that i've
heard from verified people
and the rumor is black versus alien
or extraterrestrial et's
you know i have a lot of black friends
that have told me that there is
low key beef between extraterrestrials
and
the urban community um
do you know any rally any ra what groups
that have racial tension
um
japanese and germans there you go
and there you go right from the little
horse's mouth right there you heard it
and where'd you hear about it um in
school for one
okay but also for another you know a few
of my friends that are german
sorry about that i have
an email account but here's what i'm
thinking is the one
the way we get to the future because you
see a lot of these fellas now a lot of
these ladies that are doing well when
it's
mixed culture you got your patrick
mahomes is out there
this guy i mean who knows what he's
doing this dude do anything he wants
you got who's somebody that's mixed that
does well riley
um me
who else i'm trying to think of a female
there's definitely other people
but here's what i'm saying is that this
i think eventually all the ra
every race will be mixed in two three
centuries you're gonna have everybody is
gonna be
part everything and then that's when
everything gets unlocked you know like
we kind of unlock some of the key to the
universe
when you get to that
you know that kind of captain planet um
type [ __ ] basically
because here's the thing that's the
thing it's a magic deal
because everybody's still you know
people still kind of cornering off for
their respect
people still blocking out posting up for
their own races a lot
and um i think the the key to it all is
is once you get all of that
all of the rate once it's all mixed
completely
and you get that you know japonatric
mahomes basically when you get that full
it's almost like if you took around a
cup at a united nations meeting
you know or even just a hand you put
your hand out like that
hit everybody ejac into your hand at a
uh
you in rally or something or a mixed
event
and you mix all of that up and you
should put that [ __ ] in the oven on high
for about
three hours bro i bet when you open it
up
you got it just a big bunt cake that
would never ever be racist
and i believe that a thousand percent
man
so i'm just trying to think outside of
the box you know i'm just trying to
think of things that could
be this be the end game
you know i'm just trying to think of the
things that would be the end game out
here
i got to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by
blue chew do you have a hard time taking
pills like me
if you're like me you'll get all your
vitamins in one hand
in the morning 12 16 different you know
pills and little nodules
you know hell i'll even put a
suppository in there and take it through
the throat
i'm a bad man
and you get that stack i'll put them in
my mouth and just hit them with one big
glass of water
try to do them all at once
but if you're uh if you have a hard time
taking pills like me you're not alone
that's why you need to get the only
sildenafil in tata latfl
chewables by visiting bluechew.com
if you like sex or uh or just even just
or even just jerking yourself off when
you're extremely hard
then you will love blue chew
blue chew you get the first
chewables for the bedroom that's right
bluechew.com affiliated physicians work
with you to find the dosage
and active ingredient that is best for
you
they're not going to put you on a 98
octane if you only gotta if you get if
you're running on a
transmission that can only handle a 70
octane
they don't want you so hard you can't
even hug anybody
sometimes you see somebody so erect they
can't even hug someone
because they just they overdosed them
with the wiener hitters
you know they just next to you know they
got a job as a scarecrow
and they still haven't been laid because
the doctors are overdosing you
it only takes a few minutes to connect
with a bluechew.com affiliated
physician and if you qualify you get
prescribed online quickly
there's no in-person doctor visit no
awkward conversation
no waiting in line at a pharmacy ships
directly to your door in discreet
packaging
here's a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com
and get your first order free when you
use promo code
theo just pay five dollars shipping
that's
b l u e c h e w
dot com promo code t-h-e-o
i remember one time just being and i
don't know what had gone on
i think somebody come through town with
a new dish a new
you know a new uh type of maybe
mexican food or something you know a new
spice or something
because i grew up in a time people would
come through town something would come
through town it would hit everybody
you know i remember a bad hit of lsd a
bad uh
batch of lsd came through our town and
nobody could
spell anything nobody could you know a
fire batch or the kids would call it now
a fire ass
batch of lsd came through town and
people couldn't
spell people couldn't i remember one one
type of drug came through town people
couldn't tie their shoes in our town for
half a month
people walking around just you know
people having to wear slippers a lot
you'd see a working man an electrical
man out there in slippers
you see people walking into the mine
with their you know shoes untied just
couldn't
it was a different time it was a way
different time
uh what else i remember heavy golf
balls somebody sold a batch of heavy
golf balls they'd
whenever they got them made they were
too heavy
and so suddenly all the men in our town
they were hitting ball hit doing golf
but they couldn't
the scores were low take a man 11 shots
to do a par four
you know men out there crying men start
drinking
abusing their wives and lying
you know so i grew up in a time where uh
a rare product or a
miss fan they used to call it
mismanufacturement
would trouble a society would ruin a
small town
ruin a small town and then i remember
yeah a certain a rare spice or something
maybe a native i don't know what
happened maybe someone's in the water
biola
you know people are just damn erect
god people were erect i mean you'd have
a you know
you'd have a bird laying right on your
front
for no reason you know a dog would just
come run at you and just grab you by the
front
and it was just
i mean it was just insane
you know it was just insane
but you got to be careful you got to be
careful and get the right dose
for your peen baby you run high on that
dose man you would i mean you will
just i mean your lips get hard you can't
close your eyes i've taken some pills
that'll
i mean that'll make a damn cry
you know make you cry man
uh what else do we have man let's get
into um
well we had a couple calls man and i had
a lot of nice calls after last week's
episode but we we got some calls people
come through
uh with some different calls and verbal
calls right here
as always the hotline 985-664-9503
let's get into that theo man hey
we're calling out here really close to
covington
hello man and covington that's my
hometown
where'd you do did you know i was from
somewhere raleigh
i did not know exactly where
well i am from covington louisiana do
you know what it's famous for
cheese oh wait that's wisconsin
yep nope it is famous for
tallest statue of ronald reagan in
america
tallest full copper statue of ronald
reagan
you have a favorite statue
can't say i do
you gotta have one man you should get
one i like uh i'll tell you a couple of
mine you're welcome to board if you need
but
there's one in um there was the tallest
bob hope statue
and that was in uh duran i believe it
was
duran illinois can you look that up
actually do you mind really now
um i hate to put you to work there but
you got to do something you know um
tallest bob hope statue peoria illinois
has a
richard pryor statue that i believe is
full pewter or maybe 70
pewter or something and they quit
putting copper in a lot of statues
because a lot of homeless and uh
drug addicts or da's will
chip it out and uh and sell it and smoke
it
smoke uh drugs with the money
so you'll you know you do a copper
statue
and then next you know it only has one
arm and they got you know 11 more
you know 11 more people smoking crack
near you
and you're just wondering how it all
financially made sense what do you have
a tallest bob hope statue
any information oh you wanted bob hope
i looked up the statue of hope in uh
friendship
indiana oh okay what is that
it is a private memorial
or monument displayed in a graveyard or
cemetery hope is one of the seven
virtues of the christian religion
so it's literally just about hope oh
that's beautiful not bob hope
but okay well that's close enough man
if you get that bob hope intel let us
know
so yeah but i appreciate it fellow what
i'm telling you is down he called from
covington louisiana and that's
have the world's stall uh stall a statue
of ronald reagan and that's 10 feet tall
unprecedented ronald
people refer to it locally or the you
are onward
we just want to say hope you're doing
good we appreciate everything we just
made it to god
uh keep everything on the top shelf man
we love you later
amen and they just made it through the
storm down there in louisiana storm
delta
and that's where we're at now we got
airlines sponsoring the storms
what that's how it is now this next
storm brought to you by
entergy this next storm
brought to you by taskrabbit
here's a storm here's a tornado
brought to you by bratches candies
do you like branches get you some
and next thing you know your house is on
its ass
that's what it's coming to it's coming
to
natural disasters sponsored by
companies okay
here's your craft macaroni and
earthquakes brother
you want some of that rabies oh this
strand
it's fierce it's just as
fierce as the new spotify
that's i'm just telling you what's next
guys
it's all for sale now it's all for sale
but i'll say this about louisiana and
i'm hyped up i'll tell you i'm hyped up
you know and i'm tired of sometimes you
know i'm not tired of anything but
sometimes i'm hyped up and sometimes i'm
not
sometimes i have a different mood and
i'm hyped up today
you know we're supposed to have a
trucker and we don't have a trucker
we're supposed to have a trucker and we
don't have a trucker
okay so that's where i'm at i'm handling
it
i'm moving forward
but dude every time i'm afraid to even
call people in louisiana anymore when i
call home man everybody's hiding from a
storm
oh what's going on we under a blanket
right now
we got 40 of those weighted blankets you
know we riding it out
yeah we having a party we just you know
we got
five handles of tito's
you know hell the dog's having a damn
jello shot right now
we out here at my cousins we riding it
out
we driving to austin that i feel like
the only thing
living in louisiana is basically like
playing hide and go seek with the
weather that's it
it's just like you and mother nature in
a game of red rover that's what's going
on when you live down there in louisiana
on the gulf coast
we packing everything up
i'm like y'all just get y'all just moved
in yeah we moving out
the rain's coming
oh man bless you guys i'm glad you guys
made it through it
i'm glad you guys made it through it man
and thanks for the update and um
and you know it gets me remember about
four
you that rain riley i do
it's cool huh yeah that's it's a lot
that's a lot man that's cool
that's one thing as different man about
living here instead of living in
california
predominantly anyway he's just feeling
that weather calm
in california if there's weather you
feel like it's part of a movie set
you're just
because it's always the same the
weather's always nice so you get
something a little different
you feel like somebody just cute it was
part of like the producer just sent it
or director just
oh send in the uh let's do five mile
five mile per hour winds
yeah can you raise the wind and send a
bird
let's send up send two birds yeah it's
spring
that's what it feels like out there in
california if something comes through
that it's all designed
but here you get a natural piece of
something
and it's nice man you remember that
there's a bigger director out there
there's mother nature's out there
and that bad [ __ ] is union and she is
uh
she's doing whatever she wants now
because she has tenure and she's not
worried about getting fired she gets a
two-hour lunch break
even though she only has a five-hour
work day so but
anyway uh thanks for that call man riley
now you got any information on that uh
bob hope statue i do
so it says that bob hope may be
something of a forgotten figure as a los
angeles times writer said in a november
29th story
about a new biography on late comedian
hope entertainer of the center okay what
about the statue bubba
there is a nine foot five inch tall
fiberglass and intimate
statue that has stood for 34 years
in uh rockford rockford illinois yes sir
wow yeah man that's beautiful now
something this yes something you see
different places small towns like to do
that and like to honor something
tall a statue bob hope did he ever go
see it does it say
and there you go ladies and gentlemen
that's riley mao right there all right
let's take uh
let's take another call that came in
here um
this was from actually the new jersey
show and this fella came uh
came through and he sent in a video
actually
and this fellow named dan romeo yo
what's up
theo so um here we go
kind of hard to see because of this
camera angle but
and if you can see on the video here
they got video
and he sent us video and video basically
just like a million pictures at once man
right here we got dan romeo hitting us
up and he just showed us if you can see
on the video here he showed us he
he's a wheelchair man this man he's that
bionic
fella you know he's that wheely wheelie
hit man
this dude could go off a ramp and be
like that man and be wild
because of this camera angle but my
name's dan i was that dude in the uh
wheelchair at your late show in jersey
that [ __ ] was funny as [ __ ] i don't
think we expected anything less he
killed it up there
gave thanks brother i appreciate you
daniel we saw a good laugh during this
pandemic time take our minds off this
[ __ ] for a little bit and uh [ __ ] it
dude
me and you start traveling around this
globe [ __ ] up people
[ __ ] up family barbecues and
three-legged racing and smoking them
both stay on our side of the leg you
know what i'm saying but uh
i sure do brother and i appreciate it
man i appreciate you with this call
and yeah if you got no legs man i got
two i'll give you one man we both each
stand there on it
like a flamingo you know maybe have us
you know share a cigarette or something
or i'm not smoking now but you could
take some hits and blow it into my mouth
as long as our lips don't touch you feel
me onward
yeah man i appreciate the kind words in
the shout out that [ __ ] was unreal all
my buddies and me we all watched the
podcast and we were all they were all
sending me clips because before i got to
watch it and i've
i was like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
unreal
well i appreciate you being out there
man you know and i never
you know i've always had legs
my whole life and and i didn't plan on
it but i just
you know once i was alive i just had
them
and you know so it's always interesting
when i meet somebody that's
you know that's just that's doing it a
different way
because i think life is like that
sometimes you get legs sometimes you
don't
you know it's kind of like mounds and uh
almond joy
you know and i got them freaking almonds
bro on me and you uh
and you you know you more the um
[Music]
you more the you roll them without you
know
sand nuts they call it but
uh but anyway i love you man and i
appreciate it and it's good to see your
face here dude because i couldn't see
that well from the stage
and um next time i come out there do
yeah we'll go do a show maybe we hit the
vaudeville or something
you know i do a flute and you come out
and do something go off a little ramp or
something
you know or maybe we get a trainer
animal to be involved have a little
canary land on you or something
or we have you in a box the whole time
on the stage and then we surprise
everybody at the end
and you wrote you know maybe part of the
box opens up and you roll out
you know and do a uh you know do a
bottle rocket or do something
some sort of flare activity or something
so a lot of possibilities man
a lot of possibilities uh
else do we got this episode's all over
the place i will say that
um we got this call came in
here we go hey theo this is braden from
denver colorado hey brayden
and i got a little nephew named braden
who lives over there in um
spanish fork in
uh alabama let's hear more um
with all the negativity that's been
going on in the news and
the pandemic i just wanted to let you
know about something positive that came
about
my childhood friends that he's in middle
school and high school
we're all over the country and not for
us to get together but
because of all the extra time
everybody's gotten everybody working
remotely
we have set up a dungeons and dragons
campaign
that meets up uh once a week
so every thursday we get together and we
hunt dragons and do all sorts of fun
stuff together and uh
look i think oh man
i don't even know how to get into this i
think it's beautiful you guys are
getting together man do i think the
dungeons and dragons
always never really didn't know how to
handle that vibe
you know you'd always be you'd see
people meeting up in the back of a quiz
nose or something at night
and some guy's got a purple beard and
he's got you know his ladies got them
big
big big beefy tits you know them big
freaking them slush guppies dog them
just damn like a damn
just big ol tits you know
kind of tits you hear somebody rev a
truck when you see them just
right when you see them like damn
you know that titties got octane you
know just you feel that titty
a little you see that t you know like uh
the kind of breast is so big it could
tell you're looking at it
so you look the other way out of sheer
just embarrassment or you know
mild shame but men meeting up to play
dungeons and dragons at night man i'll
tell you this i remember when i was in
junior high
and i was good in junior high and
and i saw they had some kids playing it
outside one day
and you'd see every you know one of the
kids looked like rapunzel and it was a
boy
you know and he'd have his hair braided
into a
you know into the other kid was wearing
his hair braid as a damn scarf and they
were all it was just wild [ __ ]
you'd have some guy would have his nose
his septum pierced then he'd have a
spare key hanging off it
you know to get into school and all of
them hated gym class these were the kids
who did not like gym class and i saw
uh a big goal we didn't get a lot of
goals you know seagulls pelicans
we didn't get a lot of them flying over
campus when i was in junior high but
every now and then
the winds would switch over there over
the um
poncho train and a pelican would come
come by and i saw a pelican defecate
onto a damn uh
dungeons and dragons game
and uh that [ __ ] made me feel good man
honestly when it happened
may the pelicans
be ever in your favor my friend
what about the news ryan why don't you
peep the news and uh get it ready for us
i'm going to
tell everybody about one of our sponsors
right here
and i want to tell you guys that um
that there's something called fairy
and if you're not familiar with it you
should know
with these times right now i feel like
fashion is over
you know you see somebody wearing a
triscuit uh box as a helmet
you'll see somebody wearing a damn uh
you know you'll see somebody with a mask
made out of a damn uh craft single
in the words of my friend trevor wallace
that's what he says you know he saw a
man with a
you know wearing a craft single as a
mask
you know people are different there's
different trends so how are we supposed
to know what to shop for
right now well don't buy for
now buy for forever
for timeless pieces that will last a
lifetime of where
check out farity farady
farady makes high quality comfortable
clothing
for life that's right high quality
comfortable clothing for life
you know gone are the days when you go
get you a little singlet or something
get you a new panty oh i don't have a
panic get you one boy
get you a little panty bucko
every piece is made to last a lifetime
you're gonna need it guys the end of the
world is right around the corner
what are you gonna wear something that
will last a month
f no this company is run by the fairty
family
and they are very hands on in ensuring
everything they do
lives up to their values the fairty
style
is well it's one of its own
but it's one that you'll find
comfortable and one that you'll find
almost legendary
in fact the legend collection is
legendary it's the softest coziest
shirt i've ever worn
it's a good thing the quality stands up
to everyday wear because i want to wear
it every day
that's right i want to wear my farady
every day
buying forever is the smartest way to
shop right now
and now's the smartest time to do it
right now you can get 25
off your next farady purchase when you
go to faradybrand.com
theo that's f a h e
r t y ferrity brand
dot com slash theo
for twenty five percent off fairty
brand.com
theo rally meow hit us with a news item
brother
well in a british wildlife park they
have removed five cursing parrots from
public
okay when you say cursing parrots what
do you mean like parrots that they're
what
casting spells on on public
i mean that they have foul language oh
vowels have foul language okay
and any other information they're giving
you um it just says that the birds
shared the ability to curse up a storm
something they engaged in quite often
okay so they're doing it and where is it
happening you said
in a british wildlife park yep
yep you know when i was young raleigh
you'd see a um
when i was young you'd see a mobile zoo
was popular
you know and that was a man had a nice
van or an extended van even sometime a
church van
and this man you know a man would have a
mobile zoo
and so you know somebody come through
town with a chimp and a uh
a small dolphin in an aquarium or
something in a big van you know and you
you know pay a dollar go see it or
somebody come through roll through with
two chimps and a beagle
and that was maybe 75 you go see the you
know
see them and sometimes the beagle try to
mate with everybody beetle
beagle you know a deranged beagle will
[ __ ] anything
and that's probably that's practically
scripture man uh
but we had a fella come through town one
time and he had a couple of starlings i
believe
they were birds and um
and they curse you go give them a dollar
half dollar
and they call you the n word call you
the s word
you know call you a jew for a dollar
they call you a jew
and it was just a different time
uh
it was just a different time you know
when a man when a traveling zoo was more
you know they didn't have as much legal
issues
nowadays some you know you know friend
of mine got bit outside of a bj's pizza
by a damn uh
by a australian shepherd
and that's a lawsuit whereas when i was
young you'd pay maybe 50 cents for that
so we're living in different times man
um
and i'd be lying if i didn't tell you i
spent a couple dollars over there
because this fellow's little zoo broke
down by us and you get over here in a
starling we'd call you this or call you
that
you know sometime for you know dollar
fifty you could get you know
two n words and a jew out of the guy or
something you know out of the
thing or you know just you know you
could strike up a deal
and what kind of uh birds were they
riley does it say
um they are the
african african uh grey parrots
okay so that's almost i mean
let's be honest bro if it's african gray
that's almost a black
that's a you know that's an
african-american bird
you know i mean i know there's different
ways to say it and but still it's like
so if they're dropping them bombs is
that you know
i don't know if that really need if
that's
article worthy you know i get if you got
a white parrot litter or something out
there and he you know you got a toucan
and he's out there just humming in bombs
at people while they're trying to buy a
mouse or whatever
then that to me is risque but
you know this sounds just like nature
kind of figuring itself out
um you know in the 1600s 1700s they used
to use cows to find uh
like i don't want to say land mines or
but explosives and stuff
not 1700's but like 1800's 1900. and
they'd sent him out there wandering out
there
you know until they
until they detonated it
so you know anything about that that
might have even been a far
asian trick uh raleigh have you had any
have you heard anything about that at
home any uh
on the home front any long to family
tales or anything like that
i've haven't no any of your family in
any of the wars
iwo jima famous war not that i know of
hmm
you seem like you might have a little
warrior in you
anybody ever told you that um no you
would be the first
that's cool bro thank you
all right let's check out this next call
here that came in
hey what's going on phil this is josh uh
from missouri and uh man i
i don't know what i should do i just
need some advice so my girl
thank you for calling josh from missouri
or missouri
until my step-dad used to call it
missouri
up mariah and he died actually
let's hear more girlfriend starting only
fans
and uh she's making pretty good money
but
lately she said she wants to uh she
wants me to be in the videos with her
i just don't know how i feel about that
i mean she says she can make more money
if i'm in them
but i just i don't really want my my
penis and stuff being on camera so i was
just wondering what you would do
and give me some advice and see
gang gang gang bro
and look it's a great question
you know i remember when i was a little
younger a fella told me hey your penis
ain't made for video
and i gotta say that i agree with that
i think there's some only fan stuff that
you could do that's a little bit
you know risque but not as wicked
you know because i don't know then you
now you got to worry about the lighting
you got to worry about what if people
comment oh look at that
look at that guy got that little dick
bruh dude two of those
to two people saying ah look at sammy's
got that little dick
you're never gonna be the same after
reading those comments man
so
i don't know raleigh mao what do you
think about that kind of stuff you
subscribe to any of that depravity
i do not then how do you keep off of it
i i just keep off of it
and do you do you have any trouble
looking at pornography or anything like
that
i don't wow really god
and have you always been that way oh
man and how do you do it you think
i mean i just don't there's not really a
how i just don't
remarkable buddy okay
speaking of riley mal let's get it here
a call came in right about him
and here we go hey man this is reuben
call from uh greenville south carolina
what's up ruben and you gotta respect a
man named after a sandwich
you gotta respect him
you whether you know a guy named grilled
cheese whitaker
or ruben harper you know where you go
you know a guy named pb and jay
washington
you got to respect somebody name after a
damn edible
lunch entree onward
i gotta be honest with you man riley mal
just ain't doing it for me uh all my
boys listen my co-workers my buddies
we all listen to your show i love the
boy he's a good boy i was a boy scout he
was a boy scout
he made it farther than i did i got mad
respect for him i'm a christian he's a
christian
you know we're brothers in that sense uh
but i don't uh i mean i'm
trying to be as nice as possible nicest
guy in the world he sounds like just the
sweetheart
but i don't know for the purposes of
your show if he's lending anything that
uh
let's see he he he bring him a lot to
the table
and i appreciate it ruben i appreciate
the feedback you know this is a feedback
circle here
and people is allowed to feedback and i
don't even
i don't even damn you for it brother i
want to hear what you have to say
and he just says that you know he feels
like you don't really that you don't
bring a lot to the table rally have
people ever told you that in your life
before or not
oh all the time
all right let's see let's get another
call we had another call that came in
about you and uh let's
see what we can do here about it uh
hi my name is henry i'm in middle school
and well i'm pretty good with the ghost
staff i train
almost every day and i hear that riley's
asian so that's pretty much a given that
well he's in martial arts so
i challenge him to a duel
uh gang
there you go and i don't even know if we
can legally even listen to a middle ch
uh i don't know how old that child is
and it could be also he could be 18 or
in middle school we had a guy named
larry or mr larry they called him
eventually
when i was in middle school and he was
he was at least 19.
and he could come i remember in the
bathroom we'd be in there urinating
you know just doing water out the front
and uh
he coming and pee right over you into
the urinal
just showing off you know because he was
i mean hell he was fully developed in
his
you know and he just had a damn cannon
on him
he had that freaking god dang he had
that
you know that 19 year old spout on him
we're all out here just using a
everybody's penis look like a little
igloo something you see on igloo water
cooler
and he shows up with this big dang
lincoln log you know
but anyway uh riley you got a child
right there challenging you
could you beat a child in a contest i
yeah i'm pretty sure i can you think you
can beat that kid's ass honestly henry
um i mean i don't know he he might be
faking the faking the voice he might be
like a really tough guy
i don't know and how would you approach
it you think
well i mean i would tell him you know
come over to
come over to the middle east and we'll
uh we'll hash it out
okay so there you go you got a real
challenge right there he's saying bring
it over
to the central east you mean
bring it over to the central east it'll
hash it out
you know and that's tell you right there
people want to d
uh doubt on raleigh mao he'll just he
just offered to beat the [ __ ] out of a
damn middle schooler
so i mean if that ain't
if that ain't beautiful baby i don't
know what is you know especially during
these tough times man
especially during these tough times
i'll tell you what else is good man
mint mobile breaking up with your old
wireless provider just got a whole lot
easier thanks to mint
mobile you know they were the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only and now mint mobile is
introducing their unlimited
data plan for just 30 bucks a month
let that sink in a little an unlimited
plan for 30
a month how much is your soon to be x
wireless company charging you
i mean i'm paying 180 a month for my
line
you know i'm also supporting some of my
family members semi-dead beats but hey
that's that's what we do
for people that hate their phone bill
and are ready to cut ties with
big wireless mint mobile
offers their premium unlimited plan for
just 30 bucks a month
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint
mobile passes significant savings on to
you
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network to get your unlimited wireless
plan for just 30 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free
go to mint mobile dot com slash
t-h-e-o that's m-i-n-t m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash theo cut your unlimited
wireless bill to 30 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com slash theo
all right let's take another call right
here
hey theo this is uh rob from atlanta
what's up rob thank you for the call my
friend and i appreciate you from atlanta
not sure what you're up to this tuesday
but buffalo bills will be in nashville
and if you're free i got an extra ticket
for you man
there's nothing we welcome more to the
bill's mafia than a nice strong mullet
that can be a full crowd but if you want
to come through and watch josh allen
tear up the titans man let me know
i'd love to see my buddy harrison
phillips over there uh
play over there for buffalo
and he plays buffalo bills football
and i'd love to see him do it so maybe
we'll get out there and they're
undefeated over there both of the teams
both of the team's undefeated zero
losses two teams
that's good football so thank you for
that
um
what else anything else you want to
share with us riley
um i did see that a man told
snake skin isn't a legitimate face
covering
there you go
[Music]
there you go all right i want to say
this
man uh we had
a lot of calls last week you know i was
going through a tough time and
and sometimes that's him that i just am
going through a tough time and uh
and i just want to say thanks for the
nice calls and the support
you know i appreciate it um
you know i just have this thing inside
of me where i just i forget
i just i just there's just part of me
that forgets that people care about me
it just forgets it it's like a
it's almost like a it's like a software
issue
where you know
it just kind of that part of the
the residual effect of people caring
about me just dissipates pretty quickly
um and
and so it's just a you know i appreciate
a lot of nice reminders that came in and
um and people just sharing some of their
thoughts and so i want to uh
just honor a couple of those man let's
get into it
what's up will thank you for the call
will
and you know i grew up with a fellow
they called will the thrill
and he invited us over to his house one
time uh for a party and
some fella had just learned a masturbate
in our group
and we didn't know about it he hadn't
just learned he'd known maybe he was
probably
this dude might have been 26 and he was
in a
middle school or junior high
or pre-junior high
and so we're all in a hot tub we're
relaxing you know his birthday party
and you ever been to a birthday party
for a hot tub riley
well you got to get out more man it was
uh yeah about maybe eight boys sitting
in a hot tub
and and this is in louisiana and if you
have a hot tub in louisiana first of all
you are
obviously clinically not doing well
because that's basically like making
soup it's basically
there's never there's been four cold
days in the history of louisiana
so to have a hot tub is just it's
delinquent
it's or you're basically making soup out
of whoever you invite to sit in it
so we got a basically an eight child
booyah base going on out there
we got a eight child gumbo brewing out
there and some fella named
cj vicary had learned to
uh you know jerk himself
off and
nothing the rest of us didn't know about
it
we'd never heard of it we'd never seen
it we'd never even seen a drawing of
somebody
ejaculating
and uh so he's touching his body under
the water
you know being secret of doing secretive
touch
and suddenly when he's about to
ejaculate he pulls his body up out of
the water
and he starts just kind of you know
just ejacking into the little portion of
the little hot tub
and will this kid will the thrill they
called him grabbed his penis to stop it
because he thought something was bad was
happening to him he was having a bad
reaction or something because he'd never
seen it
so he grabbed it to stop it and like
squeeze it and uh
and the kid punched him kid punched him
right in the neck
and that hurts bro seeing somebody get
punched in the neck man when they
when they're trying to hold on to
somebody else's
penis for no reason i don't know the
whole thing was just
it was a lot man it was a lot of levels
it was kind of like the odyssey you ever
had the odyssey rally
i have and you it was pretty wild huh
oh yeah yeah very similar to that
and uh anyway man
so i knew a fellow named will man uh
let's hear more thanks for the call
um i'm just listening to your
uh podcast
you just put out the um one about where
you
you know you want to drink and you know
for me man
i've been in recovery i've got a little
over two and a half years right now
and i absolutely know what you're going
through
um for me it was just feeling miserable
and not having the drugs and the alcohol
to turn to
and wondering like damn what else you
know i'm going to the gym
i'm going to meetings i'm going to
church i'm doing all these things i'm
doing everything y'all tell me to do
but i still feel you know
down i still wake up i have people i
said
do you wake up happy and they're like
yeah and i said damn
you know i couldn't remember the last
time that i woke up happy
man i can really i i i can relate man
yeah i don't know i think
you know nobody gets everything every
everybody gets some things
you know some people are you know might
be good at math and some people
you know uh wake up happy
you know some people like uh pudding and
and some people
can't you know can can draw
you know it's all the way god makes it i
think everything evens out nobody gets
it all
you know somebody's beautiful but they
might be dumb
you know somebody might be dumb but they
could uh
you know but they could teach you how to
sing if you need to
sing real quick
everybody has different capabilities
um and yeah one of my strong suits is
not waking up happy man
it's just waking up at a deficit and
yeah i can do all the things but
sometimes that's just
my walk in the world and so each day i
have to have
uh or each day i find that a program
if i follow a program then it helps me
um and the best program i've found for
myself is through
12 step in recovery to battle that daily
oh here we go again oh i'm not good
enough oh i can't handle this
oh i feel this way it gets me out of me
and gets me onto someone else or on the
god before i can get to myself you know
um but yeah when i meet somebody that
when i meet somebody who wakes up happy
god i'm so envious it's like god
god how do you do
it i mean that's my david blaine right
there
when i meet somebody who wakes up full
of joy
just wakes up you get that free gift of
joy man
that's beautiful but it gives me
something to work towards man
it gives me a daily battle and i and i
got to be thankful also for that daily
battle even on the days when i lose it
um
you know because if we woke up and just
had everything man it would
i don't i probably i don't know if i'd
want that
let's take another call man here we go
yo theo what's up man this is uh jay
i'm from new york what's up jay
thank you for calling man onward all
right i'm just calling i was just
listening to your last
episode with the asthma uh as
mr asthma attack uh yeah that driver
that fella had that ass and we had to
pull over so we could you know
you know so we could lung up off the
freaking turnpike gang driving the uber
freaking pulling over to breathe some of
this funk
breathe some of this funk air that we
have in the new york new jersey every
year
um you seemed a little down you seemed a
little depressed
um i just wanted to kind of reach out
and let you know um you did move
to nashville tennessee um
so it's a whole nother area of the
country coming from l.a where it's more
sunny more sunshine
yadda yadda but um i just want to let
you know a lot of people around the fall
time start to get depressed
uh due to um you know nature the leaves
are
the leaves are falling off the trees and
uh
the trees are giving off that pheromone
of you know dying
and it's it's natural man it's natural
and you have a lot on your plate
you know you've been clean you've been
sober i'm a big fan of the show gang
gang
and um i just want to let you know man
this is a normal it's a normal thing to
be depressed at this time of the year
especially moving from another you know
from a city to another city so
um you know just hold in there man
springtime we'll be back around
all right let's take another call here
yo
what up theo this is luis
uh just getting to your adult asthma
episode and
you know it's funny because you know i
usually stay on top
but i kind of fell behind the episodes
and
you know you're saying you know god does
for you what you can't do for yourself
and
you know i needed to hear that because
you know as you're doing
your sobriety i'm also dealing with
what i have to do and you know the clerk
telling you that you can't go to the
restaurant
was almost synonymous with
my cell phone dying as i was texting my
dealer
you know i've been sober now for one
month and
it's been the hardest month so far
i can't sleep i can't eat uh
but you know listening to your podcasts
only reassured me that you know
what i'm doing is the right thing and
you know it's not easy it's not going to
be easy and you know when you deal with
these stressful moments
and these instances where you just want
to binge it's
it's hard man wow man yes
yeah it's hard yeah it's hard i just got
to remember that it's hard
sometimes you know and i just
you know it just means a lot man i
appreciate it i really do
and um yeah your phone dying while
you're texting your dealer that's wild
what a blessing on it's crazy
and yeah for some people and some people
say well hey man just have a drink or go
party one night and let the edge out and
that's fine that's definitely an option
but i just when i when i don't want to
do that option
and some people don't have a problem if
you don't have a problem
then it's then it then more power to you
you know i'll tickle your cousin while
you do a line off his ass bro you know
what i'm saying dude i'm out there
i'm out there bruh you know
i'll freaking you know
you know i'll give you a stepmother a
zerbert bruh
while she's doing a line bro or
something whatever we got to do you know
i i mean
but i just if i go out like that then i
who
i don't know if i'm coming back
sometimes because i like to ride
that dust you feel me
you know what i'm saying i like to all
aboard on that dust donkey son
that's where i'm at if you find me bruh
i'll be out there on that dust
i'll i'll freaking i'll snort a ring off
a saturn baby you feel me
i'll snort a ring off of saturn son
so i just got to be careful with it
but man i'm glad i'm glad you got a
month man it makes me feel good for you
and just
not feel good for you it just makes me
feel ha i'm just happy that you feel
good for you
yeah man because that's powerful it's
just powerful
um so
but yeah man thank you guys for all the
kind messages and stuff and what have i
done this week to take care of myself a
little bit better
um well for one i was coming down off
probably off of testosterone i would
i've been taking testosterone
um that trt replacement stuff like that
and so there probably could have been
some side effects of that
um you know
uh but this week i've been just trying
to stay more uh
busier with my running um
working with a new therapist um
making a gratitude list every day and
really sticking to it
and even recording my gratitude list on
audio in the senate
to some of my buddies who also make them
and having them send it back you know no
homo bro or yes homo whatever
but uh that's the kind of stuff that
that this past week has been saving me
um and just keeping me in a
and uh keeping my spirit more
comfortable so
yeah i was born with an uncomfortable
spirit
you know i was born with an
uncomfortable spirit
um so
but yeah i appreciate just so much a lot
of kind words man
a lot of kind words and um it just meant
a lot so thank you
all right well uh we will
we're looking also for unique characters
to come in so follow tpw instagram
and we'll let you know some possible you
know
um unique type character type people
that we would like to have on the show
and unique uh humans
and um and we'll do what we can
and you know we made it through it
you know that's one thing today we
rolled with the punches
um you know we were expecting to have
female trucker in and it didn't happen
and we wish her well and hope that she's
safe wherever she is
and uh we just do what we can
and
any parting words you have riley
no not at all
and there you have it ladies and
gentlemen we'll leave out the way we
came in
this is paul coffin with some good music
holy ghost fire
[Music]
i got the holy ghost fire and it's
burning me
i got the holy ghost fire burning in me
got the holy ghost fire and i'm burning
[Music]
down
i got a sweet little patty at your own
in a caddy with me
[Music]
i got a sweet little yeah
i got a whole lot of product for my holy
ghost mama she making sweet eyes with me
don't let me down
of my face
[Music]
i
if you
don't let me down
me down
you